- Come on over!
Look at those boots!
- Right?
- Yes!
Oh my gosh, and the dress and the hair!
I love everything that's happening.
This is like we only allow
super models on our show
(laughing)
- [Kelly] So that's why they're all here.
Okay so, we were talking about
our presidential slogans.
It's going online, what would
your presidential slogans be?
From like your last text.
So, your name, the year you
pick, and the last text.
- So it would be,
"Alano Miller, 2024:
"No problem."
(applauding)
- [Kelly] That's actually awesome!
- I mean...
- I would love for it to
be "no problems," damn!
- [Xosha] I kind of like yours!
- Okay, what's yours?
- Xosha Roquemore, 20-twenty-never:
"I'm finna walk on stage
in a couple minutes."
- [Kelly] So you be ready!
I love this game, I will
play with everyone I know.
So both of you, Cherish The
Day is on Oprah's network,
and have y'all met Oprah before?
- You know, I met her a long time ago,
the first movie I did was Precious,
and she was a producer on that,
so I like met her in that mix.
But for Cherish, we
haven't officially met her.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But she was
- [Kelly] Wait, what does that mean?
What's "officially?"
- [Alano] (holding in laughter) because...
- She was at the table read.
- I want to hear you!
I'm so excited!
- Because we walked in,
and we were both nervous,
'cause you know, it's everybody,
it's a table read and
this is the point where
you can either keep the
job, or they fire you.
But, so, we were like,
"we gotta do our thing."
and we walk in and we see
her on this big television.
- Oh she's somewhere else!
She's Skyping in?
Okay.
- Yes, she's Skyping in.
- Well, she's Oprah, she's got a lot.
- Right!
And she looks, you know,
she's got her glasses on.
She's ready, she's got her notes,
she's starting to write things down.
And we're like, "Is this
just a video?" And then...
- Right, well we knew it was real,
'cause when we first walked
on, she wasn't on the screen,
but there was like a butler
setting up like a meal
- Putting it over.
- And orange juice.
Then she just slid in,
in her glasses like,
"Hello!"
- "Harriet's Cheesecake.
"Hello cheesecake!"
and I was like, "What?"
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
You got to talk about
cheesecake with Oprah?
- [Xosha] Yes!
- [Alano] Yeah!
- Yes!
That is my kind of woman!
I don't want anybody up in
here talkin' about kale salad.
I want to talk about cheesecake!
- Harriet's Cheesecake.
- I knew I loved her.
Okay so, Rosario, do
you have an Oprah story?
- Well the first time I met
her was just doing her show
because of doing press for Seven Pounds,
but my good story, I think,
is being at Critic's
Choice Awards with my mom,
sitting next to Common, who was like,
"Your mom's lookin' good!"
I was like, "Yes, she is!"
and she was like, "Excuse me, Common,
"Oprah's over there."
So we like went over to Oprah's table,
and then she got Ava
DuVernay to take our photo.
I was like, "That's Ava DuVernay."
She was like, "It's Oprah!"
I was like, "Okay."
So then, we took a photo,
and my mom, because I'm
working on Ava's new show,
my mom goes, "Ask Ava
"to ask Oprah for the photo
"that we took all those years ago."
I was like, "Mom, why would she have it?"
She goes, "No, don't you remember?
"Oprah took it on her Blackberry."
I'm like, "No she didn't
take it on her Blackberry.
"Why would she do that?"
She's like, "No, you just need to ask!"
So I told it to Ava, and Ava's like,
"I'll find the photo of you!"
I was like, "No, no, none of this.
"not this."
We'll try to take a new one.
We'll all take one together.
- [Xosha] Yes!
- [Alano] Yes!
- And we'll talk about cheesecake.
- I want to come but only
if there's cheesecake.
- [Rosario] Vegan cheesecake!
- Yes.
- [Alano] We'll make it happen.
- Thank you!
Dreams: check!
Um, so, tell us about your show though,
Cherish The Day.
- Go ahead.
- Oo, that was me.
Cherish The Day is a new anthology series.
- [Xosha] It's on OWN, so each season
will focus on a different couple.
So this inaugural season
focuses on our couple,
Gently James and Evan Fisher.
And what makes it cool
and different than your
regular romance show
is that each episode takes
placed over a 24 hour period.
So you're really able to get in there
and get to know the characters.
And it's chronological, but it's like,
the first episode is when we meet.
The next episode is like a year later.
And so on and so forth,
so we follow them over the
course of about 5 years
in these 24 hour increments.
- I would- y'all two look gorgeous
and you sound fun as hell, I'd watch it!
- [Kelly] I love y'all!
(cheering)
- [Alano] Thank you, thank you!
- So, did you know each other?
Y'all knew each other
before you worked together?
- [Alano] Yes.
- [Xosha] Yes!
- For a while!
I went to college with his wife!
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- And y'all just randomly
ended up getting chosen
to be in this together?
That's crazy!
- Yeah, I mean, we read.
For sure, we read and
when I read with Alano
there was a lot of like
personality chemistry.
- [Kelly] 'cause you knew each other!
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] There was a vibe already.
- It was fine, it was comfortable, yeah.
- There was a lot of trust,
a lot of safety there.
- [Kelly] That's awesome,
I'm not an actor,
so is that a lot of it?
Like when you go in, you have to
have chemistry with the other person?
Is that a lot of how you
get the job or you don't?
- Yeah, they be callin'
them "chemistry reads."
(laughing)
- And this is the chemistry
read, that's the test!
- Man, I've been trying to
have chemistry with everyone!
(laughing)